hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to would you rather now
we've got an interesting question right
off the bat would you rather be a famous
athlete in the Olympics known all around
the world or be a famous actor known
only in America now I don't know how you
could be an actor in projects that are
made in America because they are strewn
about the world but let's assume that
we're taking this very literally if
you're an actor in America and you're
famous you're only known to the people
in America and if you're an American in
air America acting to Americans that
might be all you care about but let's
assume that I care about more because
being a famous athlete means that I'm
ripped as [ __ ]
very capable but probably not gonna be
ever as famous as that actor because to
be known around the world like I'm
assuming we're thinking Usain Bolt level
of famous Olympic athlete who is
probably the most famous Olympic athlete
right now he is very well-known but at
the same time I don't know if he has the
same future potential because if you're
a famous actor you can snuff out and day
like that's obvious but if you're a
famous athlete your fame is only
localized to the peak years of your life
and then maybe after that you get left
alone and you can coach and you can
teach like if you're a famous actor only
known in America excuse you I don't know
if you're gonna go very far I think I'd
rather be the famous athlete Hey and
people agree with me okay good good to
know would you rather be be the
president or be a pokemon trainer I
don't know why anyone would actually
want to be the president why would you
want that kind of stress in your life
when you could be a pokemon trainer
which is equally probably boring because
you'd probably end up being one of those
Pokemon trainers that just is one of the
people that Ash encounters on the road
or one of the fodder people well I guess
then you'd live in a world with Pokemon
but see me I've never really cared about
Pokemon okay this is where I'm probably
gonna divide the entire audience now
I've never really been that big of a fan
of Pokemon I watched it as a kid I
played read and then I was done because
that's really all you needed to know and
where the places where it's gone I mean
Ivan played like pokemons go a little
bit and then I stopped but I just I
don't know I don't really want Pokemon
to be real because I don't want to I
don't want to deal with that on a
day-to-day basis you know I don't want I
don't want to walk out the door and have
animals start shooting lightning at me
you know I don't I don't want I don't
own a cat you know that's not really a
cat you know I like chica the way chica
is I'm assuming wait no if I'm a pokemon
trainer and then pokemon exists in real
life I'm gonna assume that that means
that all the animals that currently
exist don't exist anymore and five to
live in a world without chica I ain't
gonna live in that world so I'd rather
be the President sheerly out of the fact
that chica is more important to me than
any goddamn Pokemon and I will fight you
on that one
there's more fightin fish would you
rather taste the same flavor of food or
taste nothing ever again
so you're saying would I rather taste
the only one flavor of food can that
flavor be chicken and doublings gonna be
something that's like very complex like
chicken and dumplings could that be the
only flavor that I have because if
that's what I got then I'm fine with
that
or could that be cheese the flavor of
cheese the flavor of like Gouda or
cheddar or something like that
wait no hey whoa Wow everybody hold up
if you can taste nothing ever again
which would suck it would suck but that
means food only becomes a thing of
sustenance to you so you never have to
binge eat you never really get joy out
of eating but you can get joy out of
other things too and you remove control
of this one thing in your life like you
wouldn't have to worry about dieting
ever again you would only eat as much as
you need the same thing would happen if
you taste the same flavor so you might
as well make that flavor something good
and then it's bland and then it's
monotonous but that's the only thing
like food is food it's like a dog eating
rocks they're still happy those rocks
probably tasted the exactly the same
across the board and you know they would
love to get treats but if a dog doesn't
have treats you know that dogs still
gonna be happy because other things in
life give a joy Tommy to go with that I
would go with the same flavor yeah would
you rather have stretchable legs or
stretchable arms
hmmm I don't you know I never been faced
with this conundrum so just like I could
either be really tall at all time or be
a real gorilla like at all times so I
mean it's kind of like I guess having
stretchable arms would be really useful
because then you could play a piano
stretchable arms you could like do
surgery on a patient like way down the
aisle while relaxing on a bridge but if
you had stretchable legs you could kick
someone in the shins like from really
far away or when you say you're gonna
shove your boot up their ass you could
actually like really do it like that's
an advantage if you have stretchable
arms you can like you know when they do
that thing at weddings and such where
they wrap arms around each other well
you can do like a fancy multi spiral and
then really sip it down and and untangle
like have a little bit of flourish at
the end there these are not really
useful useful things if you had
stretchable legs you could wear really
long pants and then you could not wear
really long pants you have the
preference that flexibilities thing is
something you can't buy with money if
you have really long arms then you could
hog like 20 people at once you could be
like I could go to a panel be like I
bring it in and if you had stretchable
legs you could you could if you miss
your flight and it's already taking off
you could be like wait open the door and
just leg up and step in and then leg
back okay if you had really long arms
you could you could uh you could do that
thing to your friend we stretch around
tap them on the other shoulder but
you're like across the room and they'll
have no idea what's going on cuz they're
totally alone they think they're they
think no one's there if you have really
long legs you could you could you could
really own hopscotch you would do great
at it maybe if you had really long arms
you could reenact that scene from Space
Jam where Michael Jordan went up and was
like my arms real stretchy and then slam
dunk it you just have to get some
Monstars with you if you had stretchable
legs that means you could stretch him in
right so if someone like tries to punch
at you instead of going like up you go
down you're low
and you just kind of loop down and then
you go up again and you do the thing
where you make your legs all stretchy
and you're like whoa and you like make
your legs you do that thing that was if
that's a fun maneuver if you had
stretchable arms you could like go into
a vending machine and like snake around
stretchable arms it just seems to be
winning okay yeah that that makes a lot
of sense
okay would you rather find out your
girlfriend is pregnant as in the next
ten seconds or find out you can never
have kids again uh well I don't really
want kids right now this is a doozy as a
question not having kids because I don't
even know if I want kids
I don't maybe but you can adopt adopting
is fine I just don't want to find out if
someone's pregnant I've gotta go with
I'm gonna go with never having kids cuz
adoption always an option
lose your front teeth in a skateboarding
accident or break your hands on a bike
are you did I just did I punch a bike
did I break my hands trying to get into
the gears is this some horrible
stretchy-arm accident where I tried to
like pedal with my stretchy arms and
they got caught in the gears and is all
like snap crackle and pop and I'm all
like damn this stretch hands I should
have gone with stretched legs I could
have been biking a really tall but you
know those bikes that are like the big
wheel in the small wheel that were old
you could bike one of those with
stretchy legs [ __ ] I'll break my hands
I'll break my hands is what I say
alright would you rather be a sports
star or a celebrated academic let's go
academic I don't want to get I don't
wanna get hurt I'll go academic no one's
gonna hurt being I can be the really
long-legged stretchy legged academic
that's so that's my secret
oh yeah I'll go academic I'll go
academic also like the future potential
of an academic is a little higher than a
sports star alright would you rather
lose all lose your mind or lose your
significant other oh do they die I'm
guessing that means they die Oh
or do they just break up with me because
that would be better I guess
losing your mind that's such a horrible
thing but also losing your significant
other they
Oh God goddamn losing your mind to some
kind of like degenerative disease this
is a hard one maybe it doesn't mean
death maybe they just break up with me
which would be better than death it
wouldn't be good but at least no one's
permanently disabled or dead I see I
wouldn't want to live if I knew that my
mind was gone permanently but then I
wouldn't know so like in my rational
moment right now I wouldn't want to do
that but losing your significant other
that's a horrible thing and I wouldn't
wish that on anyone
I see if it came down to a choice of me
dying or my significant other dying I
would of course choose myself like
that's no question but this isn't really
that choice is it I don't know like I
gotta go with lose your mind if I had to
make a choice you know I I if I have to
put this as a choice of like me versus
my significant other that I gotta go
with me I just gotta go yeah I'll bear
that oh god that's such a rough one
would you rather soil yourself and have
nobody know or not so yourself but
everyone thinks you did well I mean this
is quite a quite a 180 from the last one
I'll [ __ ] my pants and have nobody know
because I'll just deal with that I'd
rather not everyone think I shat my
pants because that [ __ ] will come back
to haunt you in ghosts for ghost poop
I'll go with soil mice alright would you
rather listen to Rebecca Black or Justin
Bieber I'm gonna go with some good old
Jay Biebs oh go Jay Paul would you
rather eat every meal mix with carbonara
sauce or drink every drink mixed with
four loko oh I'm loco for four loko give
me some four look I mean I'll die I
can't drink alcohol so that doesn't work
I mean carbonara sauce that's not bad if
I just eat pasta all the time that's not
the worst thing in the world I guess
yeah I get that I just can't drink I
would go for the four loko but I die I
can't drink alcohol would you rather
have your left leg be painlessly
amputated and only be allowed to be use
a peg leg as a pro be a pirate cuz
that's what happens if you get a peg leg
you are a pirate that's all you do I
have to grow a beard I have to live on a
ship I have to go out and have scurvy I
have to rob people on the Seas I have
sort of a parent just amazing what's
even the other one I don't even know
have one of your toes be amputated with
the dirty cleaver every year until you
have none left yeah I'm gonna be the
[ __ ] pirate I'm gonna be a pirate
[ __ ] yeah would you rather pull all of
your toenails out or pull all of your
hair out I just imagine like oh god cuz
I have Tripta phobia I just imagine like
although a hair getting ripped out in
the aftermath Oh oh no my skin scrawled
oh no I'm gonna go with the toenail not
because like it'd be preferable but just
because I don't have to deal with the
other one oh god the visual of that is
killing my mind would you rather kill
Godzilla and save half the city
destroyed because of it everyone will
know you or kill the Kraken and save the
city from future catastrophe without
anybody knowing oh okay so let's assume
that the craft and Kraken was gonna
destroy the city but nobody dies nobody
knows it or Godzilla half the city gets
destroyed but everyone knows you did it
well I mean it's really a conundrum like
it's not me that's causing the problem
this is like the car dilemma you're in a
car right you're driving down there's
three people in the road in front of you
you were gonna hit them no matter what
your brakes are gone you cannot stop but
you can swerve but if you swerve there's
one person in the road you will kill
that one person or you will kill three
whether or not by your inaction what you
can do nothing about it you will kill
three people or you can do something
about it and it will kill one person
that's like the moral dilemma
it's your active choice to kill that one
person but if you don't act three people
will die for me the answer is obvious or
or like actually no there was social
status but it's like three old people or
three thieves and criminals versus one
mother it's like do you sacrifice one
for the good of the many few for the
many or that but this is not to do with
any of this this is just for self
gratification so of course I would be an
[ __ ] if I pick half the city but
everyone knows me I'm a hero but only in
my mind but they don't know that but no
one knows that anything will happen
maybe these just happen
and I I do that but to be perfectly
honest okay let's just be rational about
this
the Kraken lives in the ocean I ain't
going in the [ __ ] ocean
ain't gonna happen ain't gonna do that
I'm sorry I can't do that
I gotta go with Godzilla sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry half the city I can't go in
the ocean okay oh oh oh God
Wow okay would you rather be stalked by
a ghost for your entire life or be
stalked by a demon for three days and
then die I'm gonna assume that this
isn't a ghost that you can communicate
with this is a ghost that's always there
always haunting you always trying to
mess with you or a demon who's gonna
kill you in three days it's whether you
you it's the question of whether you can
live with a ghost scaring you every day
of your life or you die in three days to
a demon either way it's gonna happen and
I'm gonna leave this one up to you not
because I don't want to see it kinda I
mean I don't want to deal with it but I
want to leave you guys with something so
which would you rather do and why why
would you be okay the ghost is not gonna
be your friend
the ghost is not gonna like you the
ghost hates you it's like the ghost of
your worst enemy and this ghost just
wants to mess with you and ruin your
life all your life or you're gonna die
from a demon that's what it is so I'll
leave it up to you give your dust if
ocation down the comments below thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]